avalanche recently shared some new
footage for hogwarts legacy including a
brief look at the character creator some
goblin armor and this set of wizarding
clothing right here and this is the one
i want to talk about today more
specifically this little pendant right
here i look familiar to anyone now my
immediate thought is that it looked very
much like the logo for ollivanders at
least the one that's used at the
wizarding world of harry potter in
orlando florida they even sell a similar
looking pendant in the official
universal shop and after talking it over
with some other hogwarts legacy fans and
doing some additional research of my own
i think it's pretty safe to say this is
almost certainly a pendant from
ollivanders and that's where the big
question comes in why is it there is it
for our character or someone else
personally i think there are a few
distinct possibilities here number one
the first possibility is that this
attire and pendant are worn by
associates who work at olive anders in
hogwarts legacy the clothing actually
appears quite similar although not
exactly the same to garrick olivander's
attire in harry potter and the
sorcerer's stone if you take a look at
the gameplay trailer we also see an
associate at pippin's potion sporting
what appears to be some sort of patch
that could potentially be a logo for his
shop but on the other side in the shot
before the other shopkeeper doesn't
appear to have a pendant at all at least
from what we can see here we also have
to remember that we've actually seen an
ollivander's associate in one of the
first screenshots shared for the game
it's this shot right here and if you
take a closer look they don't appear to
be wearing any kind of pendant at all
again at least from what we can see here
we also get a very brief glimpse of
ollivanders in the trailer although
there's no associate nor any sign of the
symbol in sight also something to keep
in mind is that this is the hogsmeade
branch of ollivanders i've seen a lot of
folks in the comments mistake it for the
diagon alley location which could still
be in the game but we don't have any
confirmation of that at all and seeing
ollivanders here in the background is
definitely not confirmation for it
either considering this is the hogsmeade
location so while i think this is a
possible answer i don't think it's the
likely one so that takes us to the
second possibility which is that we'll
earn this pendant either by assisting an
ollivander or perhaps stealing from one
if we choose a darker path that is
avalanche has confirmed will be given
quests and helps certain npcs cross the
map now this possibility here really
excites me because it opens up a whole
different avenue of other gameplay
possibilities i mean us as the player
doing certain missions or tasks at the
request of ollivander that's a really
exciting possibility and then that begs
the question if we do tasks for
ollivander well what other potential
shopkeepers may we be doing tasks for
and will we earn pendants for those as
well another possibility that sort of
falls under this one as well is that we
simply earned this through the various
cosmetic items that we're going to be
able to earn throughout the game just in
this brief glimpse here they showed that
there are going to be a lot of
customization options for our character
so it only makes sense to have little
accessories like this perhaps
ollivanders is just simply one of those
that we can unlock and we're not
necessarily going to be accepting
missions from him but yeah that one's
definitely not as exciting alright now
let's discuss a third possibility and i
admit this one delves a little bit into
the kind of crackpot theory territory
but hey it's all in good fun right and
this one so i'm wondering what if we are
a descendant of ollivander what if our
last name is ollivander we know that
this is a wizarding family that has been
involved in the wizarding world for a
very very long time after all
ollivanders have been makers of fine
wands since 382 bc and we all know that
our character is going to be starting at
hogwarts under some sort of mysterious
circumstance perhaps because of the fact
that we were in ollivander we
experienced some sort of strange magical
event that caused our family to be
worried or concerned that we shouldn't
be attending school at hogwarts and
instead decided to train us at home or
maybe even pretend the wizarding world
didn't even exist and then this pendant
could be something that we inherited
from our parents it would certainly be a
rather bleak start to the game but
there's a lot of people out there who
expect that we will lose our parents or
guardians or whoever may be protecting
us at some point early in the game after
all it's pretty clear that our character
has seen death considering that they can
see thestrals so i certainly don't think
this one is likely by any means and i
actually like the air of merlin theory a
little bit better than this but i do
think that ollivanders is certainly a
possibility as well because they are yet
another long-standing magical family but
also one that we don't know a great deal
about even from the original canon we
have some things about the ollivanders
but there's still a lot left open that
they could really use their creative
license to explore here and i suppose
another possibility would be that this
branch of ollivanders maybe they got
into selling wizard and clothing as well
now that one would break the cannon a
little bit and considering that we've
already seen one location in the trailer
where they show us trying on all
different sorts of garments i don't
think that will be the case now
personally out of all these
possibilities i hope it's that we are
actually doing some sort of mission for
ollivander i hope it is part of the
story and maybe even ties into the
ancient magic somehow and we all know
that ranrok is trying to get this
ancient magic but is he even the true
villain that's a question for another
day in fact i've already explored it in
the video on the right side of your
screen now and that is one where i break
down 10 mysteries that will shape the
story of hogwarts legacy as always thank
you all so much for watching i'll talk
to you again soon